foreign
[Music]
Robert Spencer uh it's been a few well
has it been about a year since we've
been together
oh yeah it's good to see you Jay yeah
and uh sitting in the same office with
on this at the same chair with the same
Smile as ever
We're Not Gonna discuss anything
controversial today and this is not what
we're doing we're not going to talk
about Jihad or any of these type of
things we're all actually going to talk
about this book right here this is the
critical Quran and folks if you don't
have it go get it you need to get this
because this is a real compendium this
is one of those kind of books that every
Library should have and you keep on on
your shelf not to read all the way
through but to keep as like an
encyclopedia as a as a book to refer to
a reference book so that you can go back
when you get to a verse you don't
understand
look at this book because this will not
only help you understand it it will show
you some a lot of ideas and areas that
you probably haven't heard before and
probably will not had not Robert Spencer
taken the time and the effort to put it
all together in one compendium now
obviously it's a critical Quran explain
that why the title yeah you know Jay I
actually meant that to have two or three
meanings uh at least two offhand one is
that it is an attempt at a critical
Edition there's no critical edition of
the Quran at this point uh you can find
lots of critical editions of the Bible
and of course by that just in case
anybody's not clear what I mean that you
can find very easily the the Oxford
annotated Bible many others they have
variant readings noted different
manuscripts giving you different uh
versions of the various of various
verses they have explanatory notes
uh with some historical critical
Explorations as to where what might be
the actual historical underpinnings of
the various accounts in the gospels in
the other parts of the Bible and so on
and some of them of course come to
different conclusions they may disagree
with one another but a critical addition
is as opposed to an addition that is
designed for devotion
a devotional Bible will perhaps have
AIDS to prayer and worship and uh
passages of the scripture that uh
illustrates certain points about the
Christian faith Illustrated and
explained that kind of thing and there
are plenty of qurans like that
but you can't find a Quran that is a
critical Quran that actually does what
those Bible those those historical
critical Bibles do give you variant
readings and explanations of where the
text may have come from and what it
might really mean and so on and so I
thought well you know
JD Salinger the novelist the guy that
wrote The Catcher in the Rye he said
once people as somebody asked him why do
you write the books that you write and
he said I write the books I want to read
that don't exist so I have to make them
come into existence so then I can read
them and I thought I want a critical
Quran there isn't one so I'll have to do
it and it's just a first attempt I hope
there will be many other critical qurans
in the future and I don't expect them
all to agree with the conclusions that I
have come to in this one but I hope that
this is
in a certain sense unlocking the
floodgates and making it possible for
people to think well I can do this uh
it's not necessarily A forbidden topic
it's not uh something that is completely
off limits as the academic world has
treated it all this time
well obviously just by what you said
there's some people who are listening to
you are going to be inflamed they're
going to get become very angry because
even the idea of variant the word
variant in the Quran is anathema to
Muslims because every if you talk to any
Muslim if there are Muslims listening
you're gonna say there's no such thing
as a variant Quran we don't have
variance there's not one word not one
letter that's changed it is it is
eternal chapter 85 verse 22 is very
clear in the Quran makes that claim for
itself chapter 10 verse 15 chapter 18
verse 27 says that no man can change
God's holy word chapter 15 verse 9
stipulates that Allah himself protects
it so the Quran makes these claims and
here is Robert Spencer saying no there
are variants and they need to be
explained and I'm not I'm sitting here
keeping from laughing because the reason
why no one's written this and Robert is
no one would dare write what you've just
said yeah it takes a certain kind of
craziness I suppose uh people say aren't
you afraid for your life or something
like that and you know Jay I I
it's not as if I mean I'm I'm just like
any other individual I'm not saying that
I'm so extraordinarily courageous or
something like that Quite Contrary but
the fact is I've never been worried
about that because nobody knows you know
nobody knows the next if they're going
to have the next day nobody knows what
might happen and people die all the time
everybody's going to die it seems to me
to to to be afraid to speak the truth
and to explore these things because of
that I just don't understand it and so
nonetheless what you're doing you're
chewing off a huge amount here and this
is why I wanted to bring you on board
this is why I want to get this book out
there because you and you tend to do
this Robert yeah did Muhammad exist that
book you came out in 2011 was it 2012
blue opened that whole debate so much so
that you've had to rewrite it again just
two years ago to get all the newest
material because you opened a floodgates
of research including myself and that's
what we love about you Robert is you
take ideas that no one else has dared to
do you ask questions that no one else is
there to ask and you don't just ask the
questions you come up with answers and
it's the answers and it's the material
that you work with that you've done with
this book here no one the reason why no
one's ever done a critical assessment of
the Quran is it could it's not very
healthy to do so you could you could be
killed and I know I know you say that
I'm used to doing that but you know I
think the Lord is protecting you and I
think you do have a certain Angel over
top of you
uh fact is I I am aware of the risks
I've been getting a lot of sharp uptick
and threats since this book came out I
understand the parameters of this and I
hope that I pray the Lord does protect
me and continue to protect me thank God
that he's protected me all this time
um
and you know that's up to him uh I feel
like uh
I hope I have opened up like I said
opened up the floodgates to this and you
said as well that there will be many
others because there's plenty more that
could be done with this text
well I also wanted to just say before we
go on I said at the beginning there were
two meanings at least two critical and
the other one is that it is critical
it's not a devotional Quran I'm not a
believer in Islam I don't believe even
that Islam is a very good thing for
people and I don't make any secret about
that in this book either uh it's it's
not that I'm trying to go out of my way
to denigrate
Muslims certainly or Islam even but to
tell the truth about it and
unfortunately the truth about it is not
very attractive okay and be honest you
did mention that we have critical
editions of the Bible have had for
decades if not even centuries since the
1800s with wellhausen and they do the
University of dubigen where they came
out with strong critical additions on
the book of Moses the jdb uh documentary
hypothesis uh redacted criticism Source
criticism I mean these criticisms form
criticisms have all been have all
existed against the Bible not started
and not created by biblical criticism
but enlarged and certainly matured by
biblical criticism so in some ways
you're just carrying out a tradition
that is very much around has been around
since the 1800s
people said you know it's I thought one
of the nicest things that anybody's ever
said about any book that I've written is
an Amazon review it's one of the more
recent ones and the guy says this is the
book in a certain sense Spencer is
supplying the lack because the academy
has not done this and this is the book
that the the Academia should have
produced decades ago yeah if not years
ago and I thought yeah that's exactly
what I'm trying to do trying to fill in
this Gap and begin to oversee the
catching up of Scholars of the Quran
with what's been being done with the
Bible for as you noted several hundred
years now and there's hundreds of books
hundreds you can read that are
historical critical explorations of the
Bible and even evaluations of it from
various other kinds of moral standpoints
and people criticizing Jesus on various
from various perspectives and so on
nobody bets an eye but suddenly if you
say gee it's terrible that Muhammad that
the the Allah would make people and say
I could have guided them to the truth
but instead I'm going to fill hell with
men that's a that's that's a that's a
bit of a difficult thing to say then
suddenly you know you're hateful and
bigoted and islamophobic I think well
that's exactly what the text does say
chapter 32 verse 13 and there's another
place as well that's escaping me at the
moment do you have 693 is there 1693 I
think
I have the Hadith that say that the hell
is going to be filled with women and yes
this is going to be filled with men
that's all these things and people don't
know because even in the universities
today or maybe especially in
universities today it's all positive
about Islam even back in the 80s when I
was first studying Islam in graduate
school it was all positive it was all uh
how wonderful various aspects of it were
when we never discussed Jihad we never
discussed the treatment of women we
never heard those hadiths about hell
being filled with women or in multitudes
of other things that are part of Islam
so this book tries to fill in the Gap
it's not very healthy and we've said
this many times before now what's
fascinating the next question that
people will throw at us is why and how
can you you don't speak Arabic you're
not an air native Arab speaker why how
could you be trusted with something of
this type of magnitude but you kind of
give it right here in the in the the
subtitle let me just read the subtitle
here where you said explained from Key
Islamic commentaries and contemporary
historical research so this is not you
this is not your research you haven't
done the Arabic studies on these words
you don't even claim to do that so
explain what you have done here it is
here but most people don't know that if
you could go ahead and unpack that for
us absolutely Jay you know it's funny
thing because a lot of the Islamic
apologists out on Twitter you know and
elsewhere they've been saying you know
you're not I mean they say you don't
know a word of Arabic and things like
that which is wildly overstated I know
far more Arabic than they think but the
fact is you're right I'm not a native
Arabic speaker I'm not even able to
carry on a competent conversation in it
but the fact is that when you talk about
word studies in Arabic and explorations
of the meanings of the words I know
where to find all those and I took them
into account in this in this book and
when I'm talking about contemporary
historical research I'm talking about
people who do know the Arabic and do
know what the historical background of
these things are and I'm reporting on
what they say so as you said this
there's not this is not my conclusions
this is a compendium of the Contemporary
Research into the Quran I mean you here
if you just look here's this first page
well page 13 I just put it up open to
the cow I just put open it up at random
you only have a little bit of text but
look at all the commentary you have here
you put an awful lot of commentary
explaining what the exegete say who
these are and you use really four major
exeges I I if you don't mind if I go
through each one of them because I
thought it was fascinating you you use
uh well first of all you uh uh you go to
I just want to get them here IBN IBN
katir is probably the most famous who
died in 1372 so he would be the classic
he's from a classic period he's
considered probably the earliest of the
exit there I mean there's somebody who
is earlier than him but it's even Qatar
that most people go to why did you use
him well that's why okay because we'll
go to him see what the idea is to help
people who are not Muslim to understand
how does the average Muslim understand
this passage when he reads it and so
here again I'm not gonna undertake to
explain it I'm not going to presume but
I go to IBN kathir I go to court to be I
go to the two jalals and see I mean
that's fashion because they're four 14
59 and 1505 so you're taking really
archaic material from 13 1372 1459 1505
yeah okay
I would respectfully disagree it's old
but archaic is another thing because for
the average Muslim who is not a scholar
who's reading the Quran who thinks I
want to try to understand what this is
all about it's much more likely he's
going to go to IBN kathir than to some
21st century scholar
and these people at these Works have
endured and are still Central to the
understanding that Muslims have of Islam
and the Quran in a way that a lot that
the modern Scholars simply don't have
that kind of traction yeah
so yes but you also go to Mao Duty who
is from my part of the world he was born
and grew up in Dale Bondi real close I
used to go right through his town
whenever I went to visit my parents in
India and then moved to Pakistan in 1947
died in 1979 and you also use madani
um Mohammed isak illahi madani who just
died in 2002. these are modern Scholars
so you're using both and I understand
right exactly that the you have mild
duty of course is internationally
influential yeah and so when I'm the
same argument that I'm using for using
that I just gave you for using even get
there also applies to using Mao Duty
it's not that he's new and they're old
it's that both of them are extremely
mainstream both of them are if you go
into for example if you go into any
Islamic bookstore in the United States
right now or Europe for that matter or I
would expect pretty much all over the
world you're going to find IBN kathir
you're going to find ma Duty these guys
are the central people to understand the
Quran that are presented by Muslims for
their fellow Muslims let me just say
just so people are aware of that mount
duty is from the Indian subcontinent
that's why he's so popular what people
don't realize is that a lot of the
Indian subcontinent Muslims get fed up
with the Arabs who don't deal with some
of the more Modern Problems especially
when it comes to Christianity because
they don't most your Arab Scholars
Muslim Scholars aren't even aware of
Christianity or much of the debate
that's going on Mao duty is very much
aware of Christianity and that's why
he's much more representative of modern
day uh certainly modern day problems and
that's uh he started the Dale Bondi
movement he was the one if you go to any
of your Indians or pakistanis or
bangladeshis they go to mount Duty
before anybody else because he resonates
with them madani the same way and I
think it's great that you have taken two
Scholars that are very well known today
as well as the uh I don't want to use
the way our cake I want to use it
anymore but ancient or early Scholars
that are certainly have given their have
have been around since well in this case
since the 14th century and Mild duty is
really extraordinary uh I would say I
think that his influence is far beyond
the subcontinent it's it's International
uh I I I mean when I say I think that
he's pretty much in any uh bookstore in
the United States is there's a reason
Robert you know why
because all a lot of his stuff is in
English and remember all your pakistanis
and Bangladeshi speak English and
they're all their education is English
my duty has been written up in English
all of his material is in English so it
gets all over England and Britain and
also United States that's why we hear
him more than anybody else not so much
the Arab Scholars today yeah so there
you go and those then you have the fact
that he is dealing with Communism
dealing with other contemporary
movements and actually trying to reframe
Islam using Marxist language to attract
marxists to Islam and it's an
extraordinary uh intellectual Endeavor I
think actually and uh could have really
too in in a different way is trying to
engage with the modern world and so that
for that reason also they both deserve
although mild duty is more of a place
they both have a place in this book no
you
segwaying over into the uh you use
pixthal uh and I was a little surprised
that you use pictal for your standard
for your is for your English translation
why pictal
well in the first place I've got to say
that it's pickthall but it's modernized
and it's revised so that it's much
easier to read than pickthal's original
translation and because I mean and also
it's changed completely when it comes to
various important passages where it
appears that his translation was
inferior to others and we opted for
different uh a different reading but I
actually did that because I wanted to
defang the objection that people were
going to say that this is not a guy
who's fluent in Arabic how can he
produce a new English translation and a
lot of the people who are criticizing
the book without having looked at it
they don't realize that we're working
from the basis of a translation that is
one of the foundational translations of
the Quran into English written by a
Muslim for fellow Muslims and that is
still popular today and considered to be
in the main reliable and so that is it's
it's hard they really can't assail the
translation that's in the critical Quran
without attacking pickthal which gets
them into some difficulties and then
pixthal is modernized and revised in in
light of various discoveries of modern
scholarship various uh philological
investigations that are explained in the
notes some some Scholars today prefer
people like Aubry or drog because they
do to the Arabic and the Quran what the
nasb has done to the Hebrew and the
Greek and the Bible they go right word
by word by word and follow it through so
it's probably the most correct but
they're difficult to read whereas piktol
is much easier to read yeah and so you
have to balance the two the thing about
translating is any language to any
language there is
a pitfall not a pickthall in uh going
word by word I like our berry a whole
lot because he goes word by word but I
do find it sometimes that it obscures
rather than elucidates what is going on
for an English-speaking reader and so I
thought pickthol is kind of a happy
medium that he gives you the flavor of
the text often goes word by word but
does not do so when the meaning needs to
be brought out in a way that this
requires a departure and that's you know
that's just something that always
happens with translations that's why
one translation of the same book is
different from another yeah yeah I am I
just for those of you who don't know
what we're talking about we're talking
about this book here the critical Quran
so it's a critical Edition that means
it's going to be it's going to look at
not only the unpacked the verses but
also give you the background to why
possibilities these verses were added
why they weren't added who is
responsible what are some of the what do
some of the exegetes say exegetes for
those who actually unpack the crown uh
people like IBN katir or the Jala lines
or Mao Duty or madani these are the
famous ones and uh you've taken some of
the best ones out there I want I just
want to open it up and kind of show
people how you did it it's just so that
they could see what I like is great you
not only you not only put the verses up
here you unpack it down here so this is
the very first one the opening which is
the Fatiha only seven verses
you would think not much to say yet you
take a whole two pages of of background
material and it's amazing that's the
kind of stuff that I think that we need
to see the fact that you take I'm sorry
two not two pages two complete columns
just looking and unpacking it and what
you did is you did something that I
haven't seen yet done before and that is
you actually looked and zeroed in not
only on the the first verse but you also
zero it on the the seventh verse
those who uh cause you anger and those
who have fallen away you take that and
you unpack what is and what do the XG
say about that most people are not even
aware that those are the Jews and the
Christians it's actually the cursing
prayer against us and you actually put
it there because you know there's so
many politicians nowadays who invite
imams into say the the state legislature
over here or a prayer meeting in a
church or something like that and the
Imam uh praised the Fatiha yeah and the
assembled Christians and Jews and
whatever they say amen and they have no
idea that they've just been cursed not
only that we have we have a lot of
people in our churches who are asking
Christians to memorize those seven
verses to go into mosque and pray with
them and I uh we had a church in
California do that for my denomination
and I said please don't do that you're
cursing yourself the Muslims know you're
cursing yourself they're patting
themselves on the back and I got a real
lot of uh of a backlash from the church
itself and from the pastor saying you
don't know what you're talking about Mr
Smith and I say I may not know what I'm
talking about then why don't you just
read the critical edition of Robert
Spencer's book and he'll set you
straight because it's not you that's
saying this it's what the Effigies have
said it it's that what the exeges say
about this verse and we have to be aware
of that otherwise we're going to walk
into these minefields one after another
now I want to bring up one or two
questions I have for you yes
I want to bring up one or two questions
I have for you Robert uh one of them is
chapter 3 verse 55 which is a huge verse
for those of us who are defending Jesus
and the crucifixion you know that in
chapter 4 verse 157 it's very clear
um that he was not crucified another was
given His Image and you do a great job
on chapter 4 157 showing that this is a
probably borrowed from a gnostic uh
agnostic writing in the third Century
that this is probably the first occasion
where that could be barred from again
being very critical not Muslims are not
going to like that because that assumes
therefore it's someone putting this
together whoever the person who's
writing chapter 4 verse 117 57 is
borrowing from another source source
criticism is harmful to the veracity of
the Quran what I find interesting is in
chapter 3 verse 55 confronts this head
on concerning the word mutawafika in
Arabic
one more I want to bring up before we go
and that's chapter 19 verse 33.
19 33 on page 213 of your book because
this is about Jesus and it confronts
chapter 4 verse 157 because he that's
Jesus as a child saying Blessed Be me
the day I was born the day I die so
that's the future because he's a child
and the day I rise again when Muslims
try to come back say well he's talking
about the future of course he's a child
of course it's in the future tense
because he's as a baby he wouldn't die
yet until he was an adult yeah except if
they didn't crucify him well obviously
you know the problem there's why you
need 355 and and 1933 they confront 4157
so one of the things that I thought was
fascinating you bring up in uh chapter 2
verse one you bring up these letters
alef Lam meme
and these have always I mean this whole
part about 25 of the Quran is known as
what we call dark passages these are
well known the scholars know that nobody
understands them
just these letters are part of those
dark passages and you give an answer to
it you actually show where it actually
comes from and I think it's fascinating
explain to the people where these
letters come from that no scholar seems
to know no muslim scholar seems to know
but you seem to have an answer it's uh
it's Christoph luxenberg's answer and I
think it's compelling that he says that
it is liturgical markings
um you know Jay I'm an Orthodox
Christian yeah that's the book the
serial Aramaic reading of the Quran and
in in in in in in Orthodox Christianity
we have what's known as electionary they
have the Catholics have one as well uh
you know instead of just the pastor
explain what that is
yeah instead of the pastor picking a
passage of the scripture to read and to
preach on for a given day there's a
whole schedule for the whole year and a
special book that has the scriptures
rearranged in the order that uh they
will generally be read during the year
there are a lot of exceptions a lot of
changes a Lot of Things That Vary
depending on uh what time of year it is
and what other cons feasts may be
interposed and so on but there's a
general book called the lectionary and
it has the readings one after the other
so they're not in the order in which
they are in the Bible they're in the
order in which they're read in the
church
and so if you think about the Quran in
the first place
that's the first thing that might make
sense of it that the quran's a
chaotically ordered book that it doesn't
have a thematic order it doesn't have a
chronological order it doesn't follow
historically either the life of Muhammad
as we have it in the Sarah or the
chronology of the stories it's
recounting but if you think maybe it was
a lectionary
and so it's a bunch of disconnected
readings
that were supposed to be used at
different times of the year ah they're
out makes sense and the alif lam Meme
and all the other letters at the
beginning of the passages are telling
you where to go next
because I'll tell you something uh these
are Keys these are Keys you might say
yeah if you were an orthodox priest
and you want to do the Liturgy for a
Sunday morning the prayer service for
Sunday morning you can't just go to one
book and read it all out it's not all in
there you have to get a piece from here
for the for the readings of the day the
the hymns of the day the gospel of the
day and they're all in different books
and so you might have a and you have a
central book where it will tell you what
to find where to go to find what you
need for this particular day like say
the sixth Sunday after posca Easter and
so you have this re this Gospel reading
and this prayer and this hymn and
they're all marked where to go to get
them but you got to go get them in
different books so what Luxembourg is
saying is that alif La meme is exactly
that that kind of thing that you want to
go to whatever they were we don't know
what they were now but you want to go to
the place is where the liturgical
readings are found
that you suppose that you're supposed to
do after this section and that that's
what the letters stand for just some I
want to put up two other books that he's
talking about he's referring to these
three books this is the first one that
came out by Gunther Luling in the 1970s
where he looked at and took off the dots
and put on Aramaic dots and found all
these hymns beautiful hymns written in
Aramaic that made up an awful lot of the
Poetry that's in the Quran that was a
source for it you have this book here
that's written by Gabriel Salma who is
an Arabic aramaist himself that's his
mother tongue and has been trying to
tell the world much of the Quran comes
from us give credit where credit is due
we are Syriac aramaics and we are the
ones that can read it in its original
language and then of course you have
this one here written by Christoph
Luxembourg that's not his real name he
has to go in hiding and swell isn't this
tragic that he can't even give us we
don't even know who the real man is we
do know that he also is a Syriac scholar
and he he is the one that looked at
these 25 different these 25 dark I mean
25 percent of the Quran that's dark
passages and was able to reproduce it by
using a seven step process of taking out
the dots taking out the balls replacing
them with Aramaic dots and vowels and
then looking at Aramaic lectionary
lexicons to find but the meaning of the
words are and by doing that he not only
found that these were lectionaries he
found that many of them are actually
poems written by Saint Ephraim in the
4th century
amazing Surah 23
um is one of the found one of the most
popular
hymnographers of the Orthodox tradition
and a great deal of the poems that he
wrote and hymns that he wrote are still
used to this day in the Orthodox liturgy
and so from there it's just a hop skip
and a jump if you see that a great many
of these things that are in the Quran
are just uh arabicism Arabic sizing the
Aramaic hymns of Saint Ephraim and you
realize that Saint Ephraim has used
liturgically well then that supports his
argument in regards of the mysterious
letters
yeah Robert you're doing I mean what
you're doing is such a boon for all of
us because you're unpacking this
material you're adding it to it you're
putting it in the footnotes and saying
here is a part of a lectionary here are
letters that show you where the the
reader the priest is supposed to go from
each other context it unpacks it so
brilliantly because it shows that almost
all of the Quran is borrowed from other
sources it's borrowed from just you're
right to your syrac Aramaic sources from
ethiopic sources we now know a lot comes
from Hebrew sources we're even finding
that lot some of it comes from
zoroastrin sources sassinian sources so
all of this makes sense now when you if
you're to take it back to its original
Source it will show you what the meaning
what I love is that much of these much
of these these hymns and the most
beautiful parts of the Quran are all
about Jesus
yes he's been taken out of it we need to
take him back to Jesus but that's that's
the beauty thing about your your
critical crime you started this process
this is just the first of probably many
volumes that you're going to come up
with and I hope you keep
I hope you keep going and adding new
material as new new and newer material
comes out we want to see not only the
2023 Edition we want to see the
2024-2025 as it becomes a a real Handy
encyclopedia that we can keep on
ourselves so whenever there is a
question now you do before I end I just
want to bring up one more and you do get
into the whole kit up problem
yes explain that why you brought this up
in your critical Edition well it has
everything to do with the variant
readings that in the Islamic tradition
of course as we've discussed before and
as you've gone into I mean I used a
great deal of your own research of
course in this uh in this material the
the idea the there are Hadith that
explain and it's a foundation of Islamic
theology that the Quran was revealed in
seven readings and these are the kirat
that the the the each each one Islamic
apologists will say this is just
dialects of Arabic for the pronunciation
but there are actual variants and it
does seem as if that the stories about
the Quran being revealed in these
different dialects were apologetic in
intent and designed to cover up the fact
that there were variant readings in
different manuscripts but these became
entire manuscript traditions and it
becomes quite complicated uh with
various people than copying the
different traditions and then it becomes
more than seven because then there are
10 readers and
it becomes a dizzying number of
different variants and then of course we
have hatun going was it to Morocco and
finding what was 35 different no she
only found about five or six in Morocco
she came back to England and showed me
them and I said you can find a good 30
of them so she started sending people to
Jordan she started sending people they
were going to Jordan she didn't send
them or they were going to Morocco or
they were going uh to Yemen those are
the three countries and she says
whenever you're going into a Marketplace
I need I mean here they are here are the
30 right here here these are the 30 that
you need to look for and you have the
seven right here then green these and
I'll put this up here on the screen here
these are the initial seven well what's
interesting and you do this in your book
you do this in your critical run you
give the dates to these that destroys
this argument that these could be these
could have been given to Muhammad
because look at their dates 736 770 738
785 745
772-805 these are a century or more
after Muhammad none of them knew
Muhammad none of them were there to
receive these different dialects and
these are not dialectical differences
these are violation differences and also
diacritical differences and I note a lot
of them in the in the notes I also note
that there are many others a lot of them
I left out because I wanted to give ones
that would be absolutely clear and easy
to stand for the English-speaking reader
and not get caught up into a lot of
things that would be very difficult for
or people who didn't know Arabic to
understand
the ones that are noted in the critical
Quran are just designed to give the
reader the understanding that there's
not a single quranic text and that these
variants have existed
from the beginning of the quranic
tradition itself and the stories about
the different dialects and all that were
obviously made up to explain the
differences rather than the differences
actually arising from some decision on
the part of a false prophet or on the
part of a law to reveal his perfect word
in different versions what I think is
fascinating is ibid mujahid who was
given the responsibility to choose the
first seven which start from 736 and go
1885. he did that choosing in 936 just
before he died in the 10th Century but
that's just the first seven the next 14
which were two students of each of the
seven was chosen by al-shatabi in 1194
that's the 12th century and yet then you
have our good old friend al-jazadi who
comes along and chooses another three
kid odds and six students all of this in
1429 that's the 15th century that's 800
years after Muhammad so this is not
something that all happened Muslims
think this all happened at the time of
Muhammad it continued on for 800 years
until finally in 1924 it was
unmanageable and they could not have
standardized tests with 30 different
derivations on every verse they had to
just choose one and they choose they
chose this one the Huff's text this guy
is from al-shatabi's list he was chosen
in the 12th century but he was writing
in 796. that's the eighth Century that's
144 years after Muhammad why did they
choose this one do you know the reason
they chose um Al Haddad chose this one
in 1924
because the Ottomans chose him oh well
there you go yes there you go is because
this is the ottoman Choice why did they
choose it because it was the closest to
them in kufa and it was the most simple
the most simple to understand that is
not how you choose a text
I was fascinating we could go on and on
for a whole hour on this but thanks for
putting that into your book I mean
you've got a number of good ones there
and I see the ones that you have are
probably the strongest ones you are
correct they're uh just between Huffs
and Waters we have 5 000 different
variants between all of them if you look
at all 30 it's over it's upwards of it's
over 93 000 where else soon to approach
a hundred thousand so there you could
not and put that all in this book but
the ones you did put here and I hope
people are listening look and see the
variance he did put here because they
are all manageable they're ones that you
can use they are ones that make a lot of
sense and mo folks they don't just
change the vowels and the dots they
change the meanings and when you change
the meanings as Robert's going to show
you they changed the Theology and
sometimes they change the doctrine at
other times and they change the practice
all three things happen you can't just
have a neutral change just because
people Muslims always say well didn't
change any meaning it didn't change any
meaning it's the same word it's just a
different diet no it absolutely does
change the Theology and the doctrine and
you folks need to know about that so
listen Robert this has been great
I I know I want to thank you you've done
a great job you you I don't know where
you have the energy to get all this
writing done
but um I guess you you just have you
have an amount you must have an amazing
uh encyclopedic mind because you have an
ability to pull threads in from all
different areas and bring it down and
what I love about your books is that
your you communicate it so the Layman
can understand it
well that's really what I can do I don't
uh you know people it's a funny thing
Jay because uh a lot of times the
Islamic apologists come at me and say
this guy says he's a scholar and he's
not a scholar of Islam and uh you know
you can call me whatever you want I
don't care it's really that that the
answer to that depends on what what your
definition of a scholar is but all I am
ever all I've ever claimed to do is pass
on the results of what the people who
are doing the actual investigating dude
I do think that I can make that make
break it down and make it clear in a way
that it's not so accessible when you
read the Sarah RMA no no criticism
intended of Professor Luxembourg but his
book is hard to read yeah and so a lot
of people are discouraged and so in the
critical Quran you get the thrust of his
argument completely credited to him
beginning to end but it's it's in manner
that people who are not specialists in
this field can understand well thank you
for that you are a specialist in the
field you're not the originator of the
research you're not the one doing the
actual research you're taking what the
those who are the linguists those who
understand the material you're taking
their they're not great communicators we
know this anybody who studied under them
or you could say read their books they
don't communicate well and what you have
done you've done us all a great favor by
putting it down so that we can
understand that and I want to thank you
again folks do get this book it's called
the critical Quran you can get it on
Amazon it's up there and if you go into
it and read it make sure you keep it in
your library don't read the whole thing
in one night and well you'll probably
get a stomach upset because it is full
of material that is not not very
pleasant to go to sleep on nonetheless
because it is critical because it does
uh quote and also help you understand
what the original thinkers the exegetes
are saying what they are putting
together what their how they apply it
and these are Muslim exegees all of
these are Muslim exegetes that's how why
Robert is so important because he takes
that which many of us have never heard
they're too obscure for us to really
pull into if you're not a Muslim
yourself if you're a Muslim scholar you
will know all about the jalalans you'll
know about IBN katir you'll know about
Mount Duty and you sort of you know
about madani those are well-known names
but you all knew that so that's why let
Robert do that for you thank you for
your efforts thank you for your energy
thank you for this book I can't wait to
make sure that I keep going from page to
page now as I find that any problem I
have with a verse I'm just going to use
this by my side to be able to unpack it
and also to be able to argue with
Muslims because this is their book they
need to know about how it was put
together and why what it's saying is why
it's saying what it's saying
anything you want to say
uh I really appreciate you discussing
this uh I do think people need to know
in America what's going on what the
Quran is all about a lot of people think
uh the problem of jihad terrorism is
something that's from the early 2000s
we're all through that now it's all over
unfortunately that's not the case we're
going to hear from the jihadis again and
we need to know what they are all about
that's been the big failing actually the
American government and law enforcement
that they've decided that they don't
need to know anything about what these
people believe or why they believe it
what their motives and goals are that's
another thing that the book is designed
to elucidate yeah
listen everything that we're finding
that the jihadis are doing that Isis did
that Al-Qaeda does the Boko Haram it all
comes out of this book it comes straight
out of the Quran and then understand
that you need this book to help you
unpack it uh I I want to thank you again
Robert for putting it together so that
we have it I want people to go out and
buy it as much quickly give it to others
you should have it on your shelves
anyhow this has been great unpacking it
for you all this is Robert and Jay a few
hundred miles apart over now
foreign
[Music]